[Musik]
pauli muss wasser
vorjahr
nur zwölf minuten
ernsthaft
herzlich willkommen zum wachsen wir
waren schon lange nicht mehr da und ich
war schon lange nicht mehr da im monat
fünf minuten mit nicht ganz ganz viel
stress über die ganzen
feiertage über die ganzen egal wie auch
immer und der könig war schon lange da
also habe ich auch sehr oft an
geschrieben wo ist eigentlich gummi ihr
wisst ja der gründe ist der vorstand der
kleinkriminellen bei uns hier in
waghäusel und er war seit monaten nicht
mehr da das problem ist einfach wenn die
leute alle fragen ich darf hier auch
nicht erzählen was er gerade hat oder
was er gerade macht und darf er nicht
seine krankenakte publik machen dass er
nicht ganz normal ist das wissen wir
alle aber endlich ist er wieder da
weil ihr alle danach gefragt habe bin
ich hier die menschen haben nicht
vermisst
jetzt kann's ja also ich hab es ja nicht
erzählen aber jetzt kannst du ja selber
sagen was warum den letzten sechs
monaten nicht da war damals ja ich habe
ja die bundesregierung hat tests
durchgeführt und herausgefunden dass es
total sinnlos ist
[Gelächter]
die haut ist
in quarantäne
täglichen desinfektionsmittel waren
alles zu verdanken
wir müssen weitermachen wir in raten er
merkt wie merkt schon erst bist voll
geladen es ist es wut oder verzweiflung
das hat sie anfang gestellt und diese an
thora talsperre erhalten dann irgendwann
über läuft das wasser kann man ab weil
wir können die aggressionen schreiben
mit abbau- und jetzt bin ich wieder da
auf jeden fall ich freue mich richtig
wir machen nur ein ganz ganz tolles
rezept und zwar machen mir nicht gerecht
das heißt auf deutsch und hat meistens
alles in einen topf der eindruck
kann es sein dass du auch so ein eintopf
wissen ja es
ist ein ort zwischen gericht und zwar
machen wir das mit araki
nudeln so trete ratlos sind das hier
auf türkisch heißen sie
ist das
okay
oder man sagt auch die sony dazu und
ganz ganz einfaches rezept die zutaten
die hier sehen sind ziemlich viel aus
also hast mannschaft noch zehnmal
so dass cannabis trasse genau wenn du
nur bis 2 also mach es wie immer so also
alles was mehr als 15 taten sind macht
hier normalerweise nicht zu
staffeln und macht zwei gerichte daraus
also wieder ein ganz ganz einfaches wort
mit zusammen so dick ist eine knoblauch
wurst
also ich dich anschauen
so ist den knoblauch muss natürlich auch
richtig lecker und die zutaten sind ganz
ganz einfach farbstoff glutamat
knoblauch knoblauch fed
alles was ein ungesund ist muss man ganz
ganz ehrlich sagen aber schmecken fertig
sagte es seien noch ja wir haben wir
haben alles wäre ein museum
wir haben alles überlegt richtig
hiroshima tschernobyl ist noch durch die
social überleben auch noch so auf jeden
fall
20 sagt aber ich
bin auch so gelassen ja ein halbes jahr
lang nicht so richtig geladen wir fangen
jetzt an das auto und ich zeige euch die
zutaten 300 gramm reis nudeln eine
knoblauchzehe 2 türkische grüne paprika
15 grüne oliven ohne stein
27 gemüsebrühe
ein teelöffel kurkuma zwei esslöffel
tomatenmark an halben teelöffel harissa
da könnt ihr auch die paste nehmen
zwei teelöffel salz
125 gramm väter
fünf blätter minze
100 gramm hoch ulla
und ein esslöffel olivenöl
ja die ganzen zutaten sieht bisschen
viel aus sind aber ganz ganz easy
bekommt ja ich überall vornehmlich jetzt
meinen türkischen laden harissa bekommt
ja auch überall also ich krieg das
wirklich also alle zutaten müsst ihr bei
euch angekommen
also dann fangen wir angehen dann fängst
du an mit der türkischen paprika zu
stehen zurzeit noch tschuldigung ich
nehme hier den knoblauch dadurch einmal
kurz drauf zack spaß und gratis alles
entfernen so
bist du aufgeregt hat nämlich beim
nächsten mal ganz ehrlich
ja
ja wir waren ja mal folgende für ein
langer zeit ja ok hast du hast du mich
verflucht
nicht äußern
[Musik]
doch clever paprika geschäft jetzt
nimmst du diesen job und sie ist ganz
ganz wichtig da machen viele menschen
fehler die hat eine eigene haut okay und
zwar ist das hier die musst du erst mal
du musst die wurstpelle okay ganz ganz
wichtig und ja nicht mit der haut
zusammen so abziehen damit abziehen
kennst sicher ausgelegt
und ich nehme so lange hier die oliven
und die oliven sich einfach entscheiden
sein okay jetzt kann man natürlich ewig
lang brauchen aber ich bin da ganz ganz
pragmatisch die ich gehe da rein wie ein
heißes messer durch die butter
man muss jetzt einfach nur pragmatisch
machen ich bin ja kein sternekoch und du
auch nicht genau
nichts zu tun
[Musik]
so
dass wir die ganzen jahre nicht auffalle
ist und ich hab ich bin jetzt erst
aufkommen
echt jetzt ohne die jetzt aufgekommen
ich glaube ehrlich jetzt
du bist du
das ist spaß muss sein jetzt einmal
geschnitten bin ich schon mal als
olivenöl gegeben dankeschön so würde man
jetzt immer einfach ein bisschen
olivenöl ton ist gerade die pfanne und
ein bisschen reicht ja nicht zu viel
olivenöl erstens ist teuer und zweitens
hat die social kurs wirklich genug fett
die ich wirklich fett genug die wurst
und er ist zumal sie gerade dies ganz
kurz scharf anbraten
[Musik]
jetzt einfach kurz auf starker hitze
richtig anbraten bis richtig dunkel ist
und nicht zu viel olivenöl weil die
wurst hat mich genug fett
ist richtiggehend maribor dran
ist auch konkret und jetzt demokratie
paprika brand ich glaube die heißt die
heißen charleston oder irgendwie so
heißen die paprikasorten
charleston irgendwie sonst keine angst
ja irgendwie so hat keine ahnung was wir
haben schöne landschaft ist ein
türkisches paprika die kriegst du einen
lebens hübschen laden aber du kriegst
auch überall anders sein
kann zwar auch hin ja aber ich mag
keinen rot nicht diesen eher süßliches
richtig gehen ja
schön anbraten bis sie richtig dunkel
sind sie ganz bewusst ist und noch
nobler auch mit anführte ja ja hast du
recht genießt dankeschön bin ich froh
dass richtig habe
aufsagen knoblauch natürlich audi zieht
weil die knoblauch wusste ich schon
knoblauch ich genug aber ein bisschen
aber so genau sagen was zum rand markt
dankeschön dankeschön
sagte streben wir sind keine freunde
sagt gezwungen
so richtig schön tomatenmark betreibt
und es ist so wirklich sehr dürftig aus
meiner kindheit kenne wenn meine mama
mir morgens was zu essen gemacht hat
es war die logen und hannover
haben wir haben früher lediglich wir
haben früher sehr sehr selten gleich
gegessen wirklich
so ich kann jetzt die wird zu haben
gratis prokurist genau bis jetzt runter
schalten dort spricht nicht alles an
kurkuma genau dieser die coole farbe
harissa des pariser kann man übrigens
auch als als das habe auch daheim als
wie paprika aus der tube genau so ein
bisschen runter das ist nicht anbrennt
zu aber jetzt gemüsebrühe ja man kann
auch ein bisschen noch olivenöl
reinschicken gesagt
dass olivenöl kann sie nicht zu viel
machen wenig das wäre so als habe man
gemüsebrühe ja sieht aus wie dein hirn
oder soll ich das sonst das selbst so
flockig
wieder hoch ok
und der gemüsebrühe einfach das rezept
von der seite nehmen er braucht nur
sieben liter
das geht jetzt auch alles so ratz fatz
eigentlich ja dafür sind das beste koch
team im deutschen fernsehen schneider
malweise
so jetzt den rucola und blätter und in
linz blätter und ich tun solange das
wasser hoch kochen und wenn das wasser
richtig warm ist richtig heiß ist dann
tue ich die reisnudeln mit rein
so jetzt kochen die
nudeln das wasser kocht jetzt kann man
die nun drei macht bin ich
[Applaus]
so reis nudeln kennst du reist würden
dass sie auch schuldig ist kennst du
nicht kennt weil was der bauer nicht
kennt das frisst er nicht na ja
jetzt ziehen sie richtig schön das
wasser das ganze flüssigkeit wird wird
aufgesaugt und bestellten dansk welt
einfach man merkt dass dann die sonne
kreist das ist quell kann es sein dass
du auch im warmen wasser eingelegt war
schnell du bist ja auch schon na ja aber
ich bin ja das packe die ich bin ja groß
und schlank du bist mir also die
regazzoni der kleine wurst die
[Gelächter]
gewerkschaft schon das wasser nicht
weggezogen bin ich unglaublich es ist
ganz normal hartweizengrieß cool was hat
weiß ich ja dass ein hartweizengrieß
drin das macht dann die nudeln
mindestens so richtig schön bissfest und
lassen uns gerade halten aber zu langsam
umgesetzt werden
stimmt ja aber bei reis nun ist es gar
nicht so aktuell ich mag es besser als
ente aber wenn man nicht an der station
bei risen und ist nicht so schwarz wie
barbarisch da kann man nur schlucken
jetzt lassen wir nicht wissen aufkochen
und tun jetzt einfach den deckel drauf
warten jetzt mal ein paar minuten bis
der reis oder verdi die reis 0 richtig
bis westen und der zwischenzeit steige
in rucola
so jetzt gucke nur noch rein er sieht
noch ziemlich flüssig aus man sieht es
auch wie eine suppe aber keine angst das
zieht noch alles in ordnung habe da kein
stress da passiert jetzt gar nicht das
riecht schon richtig cool nach der
grünen paprika nach der job war
wunderschöne paprika wenig grüne paprika
so jetzt sein muss kam mal für viel und
köcheln lassen
genau und jetzt muss man abspecken und
spenden einfach aber nicht den oscar
loya ich so viel rein gemacht wenn wir
wieder gespart haben
und sagt viel schmeckt ob die nun in bis
west sind
man merkt es schärfer es wird ein
bisschen zeit direkt
und noch 1 minute noch glücklich sagt
gesehen
ja das sind die taschen liebe tricks das
hochwerfen gleicher weg
und das reicht
jetzt auch noch machen könnten ist aber
noch da wenn ihr bock haben ist aber
reine geschmackssache ihr könnt noch bis
ins exil iranischen kohl cdu leven ist
das krass ist das der grund ich solche
rezept zum ersten mal man also habe ich
noch nie gemacht werden und zwar gegen
uns einfach leute irgendwie rezepte mit
wochen sie danach
hammer
schmeckt gut sooo gut habe ich gut
gemacht ja
so und jetzt wenn wir den rucola jetzt
auch richtig kurzmann coolen jamie
oliver muss und zwar sehen wir da rein
und du chocolat einfach
darunter eben genau und die oliven genau
die oliven und in rucola machen wir nur
rein für die instagram moments jetzt so
ein tolles aussehen genau
frau dich ruhig screening genau und
genauso wie jamie oliver so rein und
zack und fertig tolles aussehen kann es
mal ein handy bringen ganz kurz bevor
ich bekommen wir dann einmal richtig
cooles bild
sorgt mit seinen händen kommen wir zwei
so jetzt machen wir mal gucken
29 wird so wie meine kumpels daheim
soll dieses bild habe ich jetzt gerade
gemacht und das passt jetzt bei
instagram dann geht's weiter
weil das unternehmen heißt nämlich immer
zwei stück und tue ich jetzt so siehst
du das so
mussten wir wollen genau
die minze noch genau
zum schluss genug ist klein schneiden
oder mitte die presse mit dem finger
knie die presse mal richtig mit dem
finger sollte sagt man du hast gesagt
jetzt machen wir folgendes jetzt
einmalig und erhebe weil das muss ganz
nah und erhebende
stimmt in der käse drauf ist kann es
nicht mehr unter dem stimmt das nur
weisheiten ist ja der wahnsinn
war jetzt das foto und wenn wir das foto
fertig haben dann probier mal und das
gute ist wir haben noch mal als special
guest da darf jetzt gleich noch mal
probieren ausmachen herr tauss man alles
sagen
und jetzt kommt dieser meine hände sind
übrigens gewaschen ganz ganz wichtig war
mir möchte ich das nochmal eine pandemie
ausbrechen vor dass dann ein
wenn ich habe das gefühl wenn da gilt es
mit den händen hände machbar wo an unser
gleichen block
dann macht die mama ist aus organisiert
sie schön drauf weil es echt schön
aussieht wenn man jetzt ein cooles foto
schmecken tut sie hat und ich liebe
diesen salzigen geschmack von diesem von
diesen fetakäse richtig lecker boah das
ist richtig cool aus jetzt wo man
richtig genial es bild
und dann lassen wir gleich unseren
besucher probieren
jetzt haben die fotos gemacht und ich
und jetzt brauchen jemand der probiert
so die portion reicht ungefähr für drei
bis vier leute oder einen gummi oder 40
sibirische wölfe die seit drei monaten
nichts gegessen haben also viele leute
auf jeden fall und es ist es gibt ja so
ein test dass menschen wenn sie selber
etwas gemacht haben das ist einfach
immer gut finden
so habe ich immer gut gemacht und uns ja
auch immer deswegen brauchen wir eine
neutrale person und dazu haben einen
freund eingeladen aus köln extra hier
angereist wegen diesem rezept und zwar
philipp philipp petzschner der aus der
dynastie der hitzler in vierter
generation also direkt aus harvard oder
aus das war genau ist auch für captain
der mannschaft ja auf jeden fall genau
und jetzt normalerweise ist es dann so
gesundes zeug und und matcha tee und
irgendwelches gemüse machen wir mit
leben am limit in meinem leben und zwar
hier richtig ist noch alles offen
philipp
dienstes job wirklich selber zur sog ist
eine türkische knoblauch muss
genau die ist voll mit glutamat herrlich
vorabstimmung voll mit mit trans
transfettsäuren genau so
fährt pro jahr führt aber spricht uns ja
schmeckt uns dass ich egal wirklich ohne
spaß gegangen wir sehr genau regal ein
alles kommen jol ist ja gekommen schon
kommt
[Gelächter]
das meint ja es sind ja du musst nur
ehrlich sei möglich das ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass dem rat ihr habt nicht
einzubinden und ist auch nicht schlimm
wenn du kannst du dich vielleicht können
wir ja besser machen das nächste mal
okay so kann ich auch sagen ich sage
feedback ist schön dass ich bin sehr
gespannt wer das mal probieren
also philipp der hat der macht diese
hippies die daumen kostenlos aber von
paketen drin habe richies die werde in
michelstadt
hergestellt genau aber euer hektar ist
sie hört hört genau in der nähe von köln
da komm ich her und ja jetzt mal das
natürlich schön
ausgedacht
gibt doch auch ein hat immer gesagt
ist das lecker das
ist klasse ist das krasse ist der rucola
finde er macht das ganz ganz anders
stellen nimmt dann die ganze neue haus
und tut die molekulare struktur
verändern und dadurch entsteht dieses
wie soll ich sagen dieses recht auch
roma in er im dritten abgangsschüler
mega wenn man ganz einfach schmeckt mir
richtig gut hammer er ist wirklich nur
ja ich sag mal so der grüne jetzt muss
gekocht wenn ihr wirklich also eine gute
hilft ihnen der küche die hat da
wirklich die überarbeitete philipp renz
so anstrengend denn mit wo die nasa
murat und ein schweinegeld raum stehen
das war nicht ich mache ja hier haben
wir mal angemacht habe die gleichen
alter waren murat finger weg von den
knöpfen das
[Gelächter]
aber ist
stets bemüht wir sie als ganz ganz
wichtig es ist wirklich auch einen mit
zu sein ich weiß wenn ich koche dann
sinkt meistens das niveau aber es ist
ganz ganz großen coole freunde mögen uns
wirklich
wir sind so kumpel freunde unter sich
kaum sorgen genau ein bisschen sehr weit
bekannte menschen
alles in ordnung wir sind nicht sauer
aufeinander okay das macht's gut macht's
richtig lecker war wieder treue heute
und kommentiert und was tolles und macht
es besser also wenn ich sie kopfschmerz
auch gut ja besser
das rezept gibt es bei auf cellestis
blog.de muss ich das immer wieder sagen
und damals noch muss irgendwas sagen
[Musik]